الامريكان روايتهم والرئيس ردا على
الروايه الامريكيه كتب رساله
حدود عملي كان ابلغ الرساله لمن عينيهم
الامر فقمنا بنشر الرساله وسائل الاعلام
وبلغت انه الرئيس الله يرحمه كتب هاي
رساله وحدد اشخاص معينين انا من الناحيه
الشخصيه
لا اتبنى روايتين الشعب العراقي
واقرباء الرئيس وعائله الرئيس يعرفونه حقا
من الذي وشاب الرئيس فاني من باب جبل
الشرع النفسي او جب الشك وشبهات عن نفسي
انقل الروايتين والشعب العراقي
والمعنيين هم اللي يحددون ما فهمت من بعض
المصادر انه
تخلخلت روايه الروايه التي كان يقتنع بها
الرئيس وذكرته بكتابك حضرتك بانه قيس
النامق واخوانهم الذين وشوا به هذا مو انا
الذي ذكرته برساله انه هو اللي هو نعم هو
اللي قال حدد الاسماء بس قال بالمجمل
الاحداث ما اتمنى اي من روايتين هاي روايه
الرئيس والشعب يقيمها والمعنينه يقيمونها
وهاي روايه الامريكان وهم ايضا ولكن
بالتاكيد في روايات اخرى عن اشخاص اخرين
قد يكونوا هم من فعلوها
يعني هذا الامر متروك القادم السنين او
قادم الاشهر او قادم الايام ولا المعنيين
الحقيقيين هم اللي يقدرون هذا من خلال
التحقيق مع الاطراف المعنيه مع المرافقين
اللي كانوا مع الرئيس مع اخر شخص بقى مع
الرئيس
واكيد يعني يوصلون الى نتيجه السؤال
الاخير بهالموضوع بعرف ما بدك تسمي عائله
الرئيس الراحل تعلم يعلمون حق المعرفه
بشخص الحقيقي بالشخص الحقيقي اللي هم
متاكدين انهم هو اللي وصى فيه بكل تاكيد
ولكن الجميع يجمع الى انه يعني هذا الوقت
مو وقته لانه اغلب يعني الناس العراقيين
يعني
[موسيقى]
يعيشون في اسقاء الدول مشردين ف مو وقتها
ولكنه كان كان قريب منه
او قريب منه هذا متروك لهم هم يحددون